cuántos de vosotros habéis tenido una
gran idea de esas que dices con este
invento me hago millonario sin embargo
no lo habéis llevado a cabo ya sea por
tiempo por recursos o incluso por miedos
ahora volver a cero es esa pregunta pero
a vuestro yo de nueve años la cosa
cambia no a esa edad no había límites o
eso creíamos
y es que voy a contar una cosa yo soy
adulta y soy inventora transformó mis
ideas en realidad pero eso sí soy
inventora secreta
y es que os haré una pregunta cerrar los
ojos y pensar en tres personas
inventoras y así rápidamente las que se
venga a la cabeza
levantan la mano los que hayáis pensado
en personas como es de edison o graham
bell
ahora levantan la mano los que hayáis
pensado en personas como walk en la mar
aubenas
veis inventores secretas como yo y es
que da igual donde haga esta pregunta en
qué lugar da igual el género la edad
siempre ocurre lo mismo siguen siendo
secretas
seguimos siendo secretas y es que esto
de secreto no es algo que mole no es
como soy agente secreto del fbi no es
secreto como invisible invisibles porque
cuando pensamos en personas inventoras
pensamos en hombres blancos de mediana
edad y quitando la fregona o el chupa
chups de eeuu
y por qué ocurre esto
pues la verdad es que lamentablemente
ocurre incluso antes de nacer cuando los
padres ya saben el sexo de su hijo y
empiezan a pensar en su vida con él
y luego estos niños y niñas van a los
colegios y allí más de lo mismo los
estereotipos expectativas es que es tan
importante lo que esperan de nosotros
y si lo pensáis cuántas mujeres
inventoras teníais en vuestros libros
cuántas profesoras de ciencia o
tecnología tuvisteis pocas o ninguna
verdad entonces es normal que estas
niñas con seis años ya piensen que son
menos capaces o menos inteligentes que
ellos
y que cuando tienen 15 años ya me
quieran estudiar una ingeniería estas
niñas lo que necesitan son referentes
que las motiven que les inspiren que les
hagan ver la tecnología las
posibilidades que nos da la tecnología
por suerte para mí los robots la
electrónica mis ganas de crear de
inventar me apartaron de ese camino pero
lamentablemente esto no es lo común si
hablamos de datos sólo un 25 por ciento
de niñas quieren estudiar es bueno
estudiando ingeniería en españa' y si
hablamos ya de inventoras sólo una de
cada diez patentes está presentada por
una mujer
la gente dice bueno pero si esto no es
tan importante o falta de talento
femenino falta de interés
pero si lo pensamos los investigadores
los científicos son las personas que
están impulsando los cambios en la
sociedad de verdad creéis que no
ocurrirá nada si entre esas personas no
hay mujeres
pues bien os pondré un ejemplo el airbag
el airbag está diseñado en el cuerpo
medio de un hombre que es la persona que
suele tener más accidentes entonces
cuando una mujer tiene un accidente
tiene un 47% más de probabilidades de
que tenga una herida de que tenga graves
heridas pero es que tiene un 17% más de
probabilidades de morir bueno las
mujeres y los bajitos
y es que si todo esto hubiera estado
diseñado por un equipo diverso un equipo
diverso que hubiera tenido en cuenta
en la forma del cuerpo de la mujer o
incluso de las mujeres embarazadas no
ocurriría esto entonces este es un claro
ejemplo un ejemplo cristalino de que la
diversidad es clave para la innovación
en otras palabras distintos puntos de
vista
marcan la diferencia
y yo pues siempre había estado rodeada
de hombres entonces pues tampoco tenía
muy claro este este problema para mí ser
secreta pues era lo normal no pues ahí
era un músculo más digamos pero es que
el problema no es que pensemos en un
inventor como una persona de un hombre
blanco de mediana edad y de eeuu no el
problema es todas esas personas todos
esos inventores inventores secretos
todas esas personas que no tenemos en
cuenta que se pierden por el camino de
esas personas que nos animamos o incluso
les animamos todos esos inventores
esas niñas que a través de los cuentos a
través de las películas se les dice que
sólo pueden ser princesas y si pueden
ser princesas y ahora toda una princesa
de pequeña e incluso modelo y fotógrafa
de mayor pero es que pueden ser mucho
mucho más pueden ser incluso inventores
y es que un inventor una inventora es
una persona que cree y crea que cree
que puede cambiar el mundo y que puede
afrontar los problemas y crea soluciones
para ello
es una persona que se levanta cada día
con ganas de innovar de hacer el mundo
mejor de cambiar las cosas y es que
sabéis que es que no hace falta ser
eilón mascó o marie curie para cambiar
el mundo mis padres por ejemplo pues
tienen un huerto y crearon un
invernadero con unas lonas unos hierros
y entonces pues teníamos legumbres y
verduras para todo el año
preguntando a cualquiera de mi familia
si eso no fue cambiar el mundo
hasta la más pequeña idea llevada a cabo
es inventar
así que si todas y todos podemos
inventar porque es lo que hacemos y no
quiénes somos lo que nos hace inventores
e inventores y no hablo sólo de inventar
productos servicios sino de inventar en
la vida porque inventar nos hace
poderosos y poderosas inventar nos hace
iguales y el primer paso como todo es
admitirlo yo esther borau soy inventora
secreta
el segundo aunque es muy importante
es que todos podemos ser inventores
creer que todos podemos serlo y es que
os imagináis un mundo en el que no
existirán las etiquetas o si sintiéramos
que no existen un mundo en el que
pudiéramos hacernos preguntas sin que
nadie tuviera miedo levantar la mano
intentar cambiar el status quo intentar
cambiar las cosas las cosas que parecen
imposibles hasta mejorar las cosas hasta
mejorar la vida en el proceso
un mundo en el que los libros contarán
la historia al completo contarán
historias como la de stephanie con la
cndh
la que inventó la fibra qué hablar un
material cinco veces más resistente que
el acero y con el que se hacen los
chalecos antibalas o historias como la
de la dg de la mar actriz e inventor a
una persona tan creativa y curiosa que
sin haber estudiado una carrera
científica fue la precursora del wifi
vaya de él
ella es una mujer del líbano que estudió
en el mitin y creó unos juguetes para
enseñar a niños y niñas a inventar
o historias tan cercanas como la de
noelia cebrián una profesora de infantil
que utiliza la robótica para mejorar la
audición y el lenguaje en niños y niñas
decidme si esto no es inventar
entonces las niñas que no creerían que
fueran - por estudiar tecnología o que
se sintieran menos femeninas yo creo que
puede acostumbrarme al mundo así y
vosotros un mundo en el que ellas no
sean la excepción sino que sean la norma
porque entonces llenaríamos las aulas de
diversidad de talento de innovación de
creatividad los niños y las niñas verían
que hay inventores e inventores por
todas partes
y no tienen que ver ni con las género ni
con la edad ni con el color inventores
inventores creadores del mundo que está
por venir y conocidas por todos
y os acordáis de la pregunta que os he
hecho antes de pensar en una persona
inventora pensaríais en una niña
pues no hace falta ni ni que lo penséis
ella es valeria tiene 11 años y junto a
su profesora patricia desde huesca han
creado un canal de youtube con el que le
enseñan a niñas y niños a aprender a
programar ya crear
valeria nos enseña de que este mundo es
posible es posible un futuro donde todo
el mundo pueda inventar inventando
juntos en la diversidad y es que juntos
es como me di cuenta de que yo era
inventora cuando conocí a personas con
mis mismas inquietudes y pasiones y
entonces juntos empezamos a inventar y
dijimos que no existe un mundo en el que
la tecnología el emprendimiento la
creatividad se unan para enseñar a los
niños y las niñas del futuro pues que
dijimos lo inventaremos y creamos la
primera academia de inventores del mundo
en zaragoza que no existen unos juguetes
para enseñar a programar a niñas y niños
a partir de los 3 años pues que dijimos
lo inventaremos y creamos de 'hips una
familia de robots para enseñar a
programar sin necesidad de saber leer y
que la nasa necesita un dispositivo con
el que personas discapacitadas puedan
enseñar puedan aprender a controlar
objetos con la mirada
y dijimos lo inventaremos y creamos de
ayer forus y juntos fuimos hasta dubai a
competir contra universidades como le
mighty o stanford por un millón de
dólares y ahora estaréis pensando pero
conseguisteis ese millón de dólares
pues no lo conseguimos
no lo conseguimos pero conseguimos algo
mucho mejor nos dimos cuenta en ese
preciso instante del poder que tenía
inventar
y es que yo no era un hombre blanco de
mediana edad ni de eeuu aunque muchos de
los que había allí sí pero juntos
estábamos enseñando allí lo que habíamos
inventado
he llegado a este punto estaréis
pensando bueno sí pero cómo podemos
llegar a ser inventores no
pues bueno es muy sencillo y os lo voy a
contar aunque estoy jugando mi puesto de
inventora secreta
solo hay que seguir tres sencillos pasos
el primer paso tenemos que dejar fuera
nuestras expectativas
nuestros estereotipos que nos limitan
vale para inventar hay que ser libre y
osado porque en la libertad y en la
osadía reside la innovación
el siguiente paso tenemos que ponernos
nuestra máscara de niños de 9 años y
entonces ser curiosos ser creativos
imaginar y ver el mundo en todas las
perspectivas y el último paso inventar
pero inventar haciéndolo juntos porque
hay un mundo ahí fuera en internet si no
sabéis por dónde empezar están
movimientos como lo pensó arduino y
buscando estas personas con vuestras
inquietudes con vuestras pasiones porque
juntos se puede conseguir
y es que las historias producen
curiosidad la curiosidad precede al
conocimiento y el conocimiento nos hace
libres y poderosos
así que son los pide una cosa que cuando
salgáis por esta puerta empecéis a
contar las historias historias de todas
esas mujeres valientes talentosas
mujeres inventoras y que muchas de las
cosas que utilizamos hoy es gracias a
ellas y que lleguen hasta las niñas que
las niñas dejen de ser perfectas para
ser valientes y que además si alguna vez
os vuelven a preguntar por qué os
preguntaran conocéis alguna persona
inventora y os acordéis de allande y
hedy lamarr ya se acordáis de niñas como
valeria
este haya crecido un poco y yo os
acordéis de todas esas niñas que están
empezando a crear hoy para que dejen de
ser invisibles y para que dejen de ser
secretas y sobre todo una cosa más y lo
más importante que penséis en vosotras
mismas y creáis que seáis capaces de
hacerlo y sólo ahí en ese momento nos
daremos cuenta de que todas y todos
podemos llegar a ser inventoras
inventores